the events of the past few weeks will
undoubtedly feature in the history books
of the future
but could they also lead to the teaching
of black history
being made mandatory for all pupils
zyba patel teaches here at cheney school
in headington in oxford
it's incredibly important i think it's
not just
um because we're worrying about the kids
it's about kind of the authenticity of
history as a discipline as well
if we ignore sort of black history then
that means that we're missing out
on important parts of our history and
we're creating gaps in our students
knowledge
this is the story of olive morris
a group called the black curriculum has
attracted support in the wake of the
black lives matter protests
they're sending an open letter to
education secretary gavin williamson
calling for change we feel that it's
vital for young black people
and young black students in britain to
see themselves reflected in a curriculum
where they're being shown in positive a
positive light
in a capacity other than slavery and we
feel like this is great for their sense
of identity
their sense of belonging but also the
way that they interact with their white
classmates
in a statement to sky news a department
for education
spokesperson said racism in all its
forms is abhorrent
and has no place in our society schools
already
play a significant role in teaching
children about the importance of having
respect
and tolerance for all cultures
but campaigners claim some of the
resources in classrooms
largely ignore ethnic minorities their
histories
and their achievements well one of the
issues is the textbooks that have been
used over the years you can literally go
from cover to cover
a history of the 20th century and not
see a single black or asian face
oxford postgraduate student laura
stewart helped organize the recent
rhodes must
fall protest aimed at having the
university remove its statue to the
controversial 19th century
colonialist cecil rhodes i'm not amazed
that you know people of color and black
and minority ethnic histories are
emitted
from the british curriculum but what i
think is more important is that other
people who are non-black and minority
ethnic
need to be amazed across the country
last night
people took a knee in solidarity with
the black lives matter movement
campaigners say making black history
part of the national curriculum
will be an even more powerful long-term
message
and the brady sky news in oxford